guns are not violence guns are a tool
that is utilized by people who want to
commit violence
what would make america safer 99
of america who has license to carry or
of america who doesn't own a single gun
in new jersey you have a woman by the
name of cara bone
she was stabbed to death by her
ex-boyfriend and he was a felon
she knew he was going to try to kill her
one day and so she submitted
her paperwork in order to get the
license and she was stabbed in a
driveway of her own home
this woman actually called in i'm just
checking on the status of my license in
order for me to go buy a gun
when the time came and her ex-boyfriend
showed up to stab at her death she was
in a position no longer to defend
herself at that point
weapons have changed in the last 10 20
30 years let's go to worst case scenario
beto aurora
he's in charge and he confiscates
everything away from you
what's the worst thing they can do to us
i don't know ask china
[Music]
so if you love guns or if you hate guns
you probably know my guest today his
name is coleon noor
now he is an american gun activist
he's a lawyer former lawyer he's got a
youtube channel with a few million
subscribers
and a quarter of a billion viewers he's
faced off bill maher he's been all over
the place
people love him hate him but they get
educated by him every time he talks
about guns
with that being said my guest today noor
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
oh thanks for having me patrick so i got
to tell you man you're very necessary
today you are very necessary today
because
uh so many people who uh sit there and
they have a certain
image or understanding of guns then you
come out and educate them and you give
the different perspectives you get
people thinking
and i think that's very necessary today
especially someone like you your
background being a lawyer so
you don't just love guns you're a lawyer
you know how to make a good argument
make a good case you're bulletproof a
little bit
kind of say that but let's get right
into it so tell us how
where your passion came for guns now i
know this story but if the audience
doesn't know your story how did you get
so passionate about guns
so it's it's a really simple story
sometimes to the point where some people
think it's fake
but essentially i had a good friend of
mine who randomly one day said yo
i'm gonna go to the gun range and do you
want to come
and keep in mind at this point i'm about
23 24 maybe a little bit younger
never touched a gun never shot a gun
never had a gun in the house never
raised with guns
for me the notion of owning a firearm
was relegated to only
cops um people in authority and but as a
young black kid
if i had a gun automatically that i must
have been a gang of some sort so i kind
of i wanted to do everything to kind of
fight that
narrative in that image so i never
really did anything with respect to
firearms and look at them or anything
so when my friend of mine who i didn't
even know had a gun um asked me if i
wanted to go to gun range with them
initially i was a little scared i'll be
honest and say that i was like i don't
know
um but then there was an aspect of me
that was kind of like you know stop
being so close-minded
just go ahead and try it um at worst if
you don't like it
you don't do it again and so i decided
to go
um i went and i very very vividly i walk
in
to the gun range was in houston texas
place called top gun and i remember
walking in
and hearing the initial gunshots because
mighty had opened the other door
to where people were shooting and so i
could hear the pop pop pop and i'm like
oh okay this is real um
and so now and i remember vividly
thinking man i'm in a place
where everybody has a gun and at any
given point they can decide that they
just
want to kill me that was the mindset it
was a very kind of
i was a juvenile but a very kind of
simplistic mindset with respect to fire
ownership in people
and so we get up to the counter um we
fill out all the paperwork and do it we
need to do
go to the lane i remember going to the
very last lane on the left-hand side
um and so i remember him pulling out a
gun it was a taurus millennial
pt 1000 i think it was a a sub-compact
gun chambered in 40 smith and wesson
which anybody who knows anything about
calibers affording
40 smith wesson and that size of a gun
is it's going to have
substantial recoil to it so um remember
he she gave me kind of a
real quick down and dirty understanding
of how to manipulate and operate the gun
i wasn't an idiot so i was able to kind
of figure it you know
get that short lesson and then be able
to do it myself um
and i remember picking up the gun
remember extending out
pulling the trigger and the gun going
off and being completely
and utterly terrified i'm like
what just happened and it happened so
fast
for whatever reason i decided to do it
again and it was that
second time that i shot the gun
i guess because i understood what was
about to happen and now i was able to
actually experience the moment
instead of just being put in the moment
um
and i fell in love instantly with that
second shot and i remember
i went through a number of rounds that
that trip but then
immediately after that i mean i went
down a rabbit hole of and
you know i recently watched the video
where you talked about researching
and man when i tell you i felt deep
inside that hole i mean and the
fascination was more so from a
a love affair with the mechanics of the
firearm you know i'm a big car guy
and so for me there was a there was an
immediate relationship there that
that created a fascination that i kind
of almost pulled from the car aspect of
my my love affair with cars
and i mean i was on youtube watching
video after video after video after
video
magazine articles articles online it was
this was kind of an
age where like blogs were really really
big so
reading all the blog posts that i can
amassing all of this information that i
didn't even realize i was amassing
um and then at the same time i was going
back to the gun range over
as many times as possible and at this
point i was just getting into my law
school career as well so
any down time i had i mean i was going
to the gun range or learning about guns
a lot of times sitting in class while
the teacher was
while the professor was teaching uh
reading about guns
to the slight horror of some of the
people who sat behind me in class
but nonetheless um
at a certain point i i thought i kind of
reached the end of
gun content on youtube i consumed so
much um
and i gotten filled and vibe for the way
people made videos
and so for me i kind of always been this
guy who kind of floats between them
having a very analytical brain but then
very being very kind of
artsy fartsy in a lot of ways um being a
creative
and so i thought you know i watch a ton
of car videos
and i just got through consuming a ton
of gun videos over a few years
and so i said i want to start making my
own videos not that the videos were bad
that i was watching it's just
i wanted to create the videos i wanted
to watch now at this point you've never
been a youtuber so you never had content
you created in the past before
nope nope zero no and you're not
military you're not former pd
you're not your family's not and there
is no lineage of that
nope in a family were you raised
conservative i know your your family's
uh from nigeria were you raised
conservative or not really too political
no um it wasn't hyper-political i mean
i'm an only child
so a lot of the conversations as an only
child with people who have only children
know and only children
you kind of grow up around adults um so
you grew up listening to the
conversations
and so the vast majority of the the
discourse that i've engaged in or at
least
passively so by listening or you know
there were some political talks here and
there
but um from a political standpoint i
definitely wasn't conservative
from a political uh alignment standpoint
it was a a lot of the lessons that my
mom taught me and
raised me on were very much conservative
but when it came down to voting it was
always democratic
you know you always vote democrat i know
my mom probably to this day still votes
democrat
um so but other than that there wasn't
an overt
political um component to my upbringing
now
perfect so at this point mom votes
democrat never been in military no pd
no inspiration of somebody that taught
you how to shoot guns friend takes you
you're 23 years old at the time i'm
doing the math
it's got to be 0.607 bush's president to
put everything to perspective
when you're going to become a lawyer
what are you trying to do like are you
saying one day i want to be a criminal
defense attorney
i'm going to be what kind of law were
you pursuing so initially my whole thing
was i wanted to be a criminal defense
attorney that was my thing
um i wanted to be an advocate i wanted
to be in the courtroom i wanted to be
trying
cases um as time went on um and i
started doing some of that in terms of
like some of the programs that i took on
while i was in law school i joined a
bunch of clinics that i did as well and
i'm part of the mock trial program
at my law school as well um and until i
met one of my other legal mentors
and from there i started learning the um
personal injury side of things and so i
started working in his office
and learning that side of it and i took
a liking to it and so
by and large that was kind of the the
the most of what i was doing with
respect to the legal space
but but i definitely wanted to be an
advocate and
that's what initially when it got me
into going into law school
now your friend what does he do now the
friend that took you to the range the
first time what business is he in
oh he's he's on the fashion side of it
he's on oh he's not he's any passion
yeah no he's not no okay he's he's in
high fashion
so so at what point did you get a call
from nra saying they want you to be
one of their spokesperson you know and
you became become the most prominent
black commentator for
pro-gun nra organization when did that
happen
so that happened i at this point so the
way
my kind of i guess youtube career so to
speak kind of started over my content
very much so i started off by just doing
gun reviews that was my thing i was on
the
the gun culture side of things from that
perspective and then
we started getting some high profile at
this point obama is now in office
and so we started getting some
high-profile shootings some high-profile
mass shootings um and i remember doing a
video titled how to stop
mass shootings and in the video i talked
about how a lot of these shooters are
looking
to do these things based on recognition
and then that the more we talk about
them the more that we say their names
and the more that we sensationalize it
all it does it just motivates other
people to continue to do the same thing
but then on top of that
having people in a position to combat
the mass shooter
that pulls them out of the reality or
the fantasy of them going out in a blaze
of glory and killing a bunch of people
instantly because now they're being
confronted with somebody else with the
firearm
and so it's not a free shoot anymore so
i did this video in this video went
viral back in the days when
hitting a hundred thousand was
considered viral
uh and this video was doing a million
and so that was just like
nuts and so from that perspective
um i remember there was some there was a
lot of hype regarding that and then i
was getting a lot of phone calls a lot
of people asked me to do interviews and
talk about it
and then i get a phone call from someone
asking me um
if i'd be interested in working with the
nra now
ironically at the time you know there
was a lot of
things were moving so fast and there was
so much involved in terms of the
political side of this conversation
because up until then i was just doing
gun gun reviews like it didn't
it was just fun um now in the political
world and i'm being you know i can get
people
leaving nasty comments you know people
keep pushing back on my stance and stuff
so now i'm in the political dirty world
of it
and so now i'm like i don't really know
who to trust i'm like is anybody trying
to set me up and you know
i the person who called me i tried to
research him and look him up couldn't
really figure out who the person
was whether how connected they were to
the internet to the nra so forth and so
on
and so i was a little hesitant and and i
also was aware of the organization but
i really hadn't done my due diligence
all the information i had about the
organization was very surface level
and very stereotypical so i was a little
hesitant especially being a young black
guy you know
young black especially during that time
was like the nra was racist that's
that's all you knew you know you don't
do that right a bunch of racist white
people guns
so um initially hesitated and i said you
know let me let me do my due diligence
and do some research
and went did a deep sea dive once again
like i did with the gun stuff and uh did
my research on the organization
and i felt comfortable with the organ um
linking up with the organization or at
least seeing what they have to say
and so they flew me out to dallas i went
out to dallas and met with the
um met with fair at the time i didn't
realize how the structure or the
relationships work but
uh i met with their ad agency on record
which was acronym mcqueen
and so i remember expecting to walk into
this kind of old stuffy building
with uh you know a bunch of old white
guys telling me he's like
all right do this you know what i mean
so but to my surprise i felt more like i
walked into a modern-day version of mad
men
and and i mean that in the most positive
way oh my god yes yes
um and i mean the most positive way
possible i mean i walked in and i mean
everyone was good looking everyone was
relatively young
i mean you're talking it span the span
the of the spectrum with respect to race
i mean i was like whoa you know i was
really taken aback
and so from there um
they sat me down and they were like look
all we want you to do is literally what
you've been doing
on your youtube channel on our platform
you're like we don't want to tell you
what to say we don't want to tell you
what to do
we just want you to create the same type
of content that you were creating on
your own
and so i was like okay this is
interesting
because now um and it really started off
with them saying
you know we want to put together a
series of about six videos i didn't
realize this at the time but they were
kind of just testing me
um you know like we put together a
series like 6-12 videos
and um basically you you put you you do
it basically they were just trying to
see my productivity like
how i take to that um ironically enough
this was also during a time where i was
maybe a week or two away from taking the
bar exam
i know right um and i was like oh man
this is nuts because anybody knows
anything about the bar exam there's no
joke
um whether or not it was a good idea to
do it or not it could be debated
since i took the bar exam probably three
times um
so i went ahead and put together these
series of videos i i
put together all the scripts myself um i
now remember
specifically they were gonna take six of
my old videos and put them together and
put them out on their platform and then
they wanted me to come up with six
videos on my own
um based on a series of topics and so i
said cool so i did that i went and
filmed it
knocked it out um and i guess they liked
what they saw and like what they got
um and from there that's when they pitch
me to come on more
full-time in terms of doing those types
of videos but then also giving me my
own show and so i remember this time
vividly because i remember this was when
i really started getting some pushback
um this is when like the likes of uh how
can i have i always forget his name
um uh russell simmons russell
russell simmons i remember very vividly
he's like how could you as a young black
man sign on with an nra organization
that touts this and snap
and i remember because this was i was in
virginia beach i was at i was at a bar i
was kind of
sort of drunk and uh i remember seeing
this like whoa
russell simmons is tweeting me and this
is this is someone who i kind of grew up
and i
used to wear his brand and you know
listen to his artists and things of that
nature so i'm learning like okay this is
different
um and i remember specifically taking
the time out to say all right i've been
drinking
be careful how you respond and this is
like at the genesis of when twitter kind
of started
and so i went ahead and i responded i
think something to the degree of i
didn't know
you know me advocating defending
yourself
well while utilizing the second
amendment was a bad thing and so then we
kind of went back and
forth and if anybody googles me and his
name it'll it'll pop up the whole
exchange
and what happened was interesting
because
what ended up happening is people who
followed russell simmons
started telling him like look i like you
russ i mess with you russ but
i also mess with what this guy is saying
like i agree with him on this issue
and somewhere between seeing starting to
see that he kind of just backed off
because i think he didn't really truly
understand who i was and i think he
actually under he didn't really give me
enough credit
because i think he thought that they
just found me on the street corner
somewhere and said
here's a hat put it on wrong guy to mess
with exactly
yeah i get that a lot honestly um i
don't know right though
to have when people underestimate you
but by the way who were you in high
school if i was 16 years old with you in
high school who were you i'm curious
i was a jock you were a job were you an
athlete were you a guy i was an athlete
i i was i played i did it all i did
basketball football
track you name it i did it all i
were you like the 4.0 gpa no i was i was
i was the intelligent kid who didn't
take school seriously
okay got it um and so for me
and i remember that during his time all
i wanted to do was play basketball that
was it that was my love affair i was
like i'm doing
i'm going to the nba and nothing was
going to stop me that was kind of the
tenacity i i kind of have as a person
and so i mean i was the guy we go to
practice and then after practice
i go to the gym work out come back then
get like a freshman or something go
back to gym and do some more shooting
and run more drills that was me and then
wake up saturday morning
be outside running drills practicing
doing all that stuff
but my mom was always very diligent
about telling me she was like
look son i know you love basketball and
i know you want to go to the nba but
make sure you keep school number one
because they can take
a lot of things from you but they can't
take what take from you what's in here
um that's it yeah very much so yeah and
so
even though during high school i didn't
really put as much effort as i probably
should have
and i may have just gotten by and based
whatever natural intelligence i had
um there did come that time where i said
this is not happening bro um and and i
really haven't
criminal defense attorney the white
criminal defense attorney like where do
you go from
athlete you know i think your dad's a
chef or yeah
he was a chef he was an executive yeah
how do you go from that
to criminal defense attorney that
somebody unfair situation that happened
to a friend or relative that got
arrested that you wanted to fight for
them
i read johnny cochran's biography
okay there you go that's all you have to
say
so you read that and he said that's what
i wanted to do yep
exactly wow now remember well that's not
what i decided to go
to law school yeah i just i how i what
type of lawyer i wanted to be
was after reading johnny cock's
biography but i was a sophomore
and so being nigerian you know if it's
if it's not
if it's not doctor pharmacist or lawyer
or something like that
everything else degree wise is trash for
them so
i started off pre-med and when i was in
undergrad
and i hated it i'm actually i started
off yeah i did pre-med and then i did
pre-farm and i was just like i'm not a
math and science guy
it's just not me um so i decided to go
pull a little poli sci
and so i remember it was my sophomore
year and you know mom's like look you
you got to be more definitive about what
direction you want to go you can't just
be sitting in school just taking classes
and not knowing what you want to do
and i remember i took some time out one
day just just
literally proactively figure out what
direction i wanted to go
and i remember i was in houston driving
on 59
and i remember i was just thinking about
all the things that really motivate me
what i enjoy to do what am i passionate
about
um a lot of my friends um we grew up
playing basketball and arguing that's
what we did
we any topic you name it and i i don't
mean just yelling and screaming arguing
i mean we intellectualized the most
mundane
aspects of life to to hours into the
morning
right um and there was always a very
distinctive way about the way that i
argued and the way that everybody else
argued
um and everybody would always point that
out and so i remember i'm driving and i
would always i would thrive on those
interactions those things i love them
because it was one me exploring other
people's ideas i love to see how people
communicated like i have a good friend
of mine he may not know what the hell
he's talking about but he has this
beautiful ability to
mix in humor with what he's talking
about in order to get the crowd to be on
his side
about a particular issue um and things
of that need i love seeing those type of
tactics
um when it comes to kind of just verbal
interactions um and i'm driving down the
highway and i'm thinking to myself
like man what do i like to do what do i
like to do
but and it clicked i clicked i'm like i
like and it sounds so basic it really
does
but it was the truth i i thought to
myself man i love
to i love to argue i love to converse i
love to have discussions about things on
it
on the most infinite level um so let's
go to
let's major in poli sci and then go to
law school
um and you know from there i remember
calling my mom's my mom's boyfriend
very i remember calling my mom's
boyfriend at the time and he was an
attorney
and i remember calling him up and i'm
like are you busy can i come to your
office i want to pick your brain about
something
and so i went to him talked to him and
he kind of sat down and he was just like
you know
he was giving me the reality of it he
didn't feed me bs which is what i love
about him
and um and i said yeah this is this is
this is what i think i really want to do
um and then from there once again i did
a deep-seated dive like i normally do
whenever i get into something
um you know i started reading book after
book and then i read i read johnny
cochran's biography and i'm like yep
this is this is what i want to do this
is
who i want to be and um that's when i
decided okay
as i got into law school i want to go
the route of becoming a defense attorney
well that's great man you got a good
story so if that's the case let's just
get into the debating part because i'm
sure the audience wants to
wants to see that so one of your recent
videos
uh you highlighted the fact that uh in
2018 we had 297 people die
from a rifle 235 was from shotguns
uh a thousand 515 was from stabbing
672 was killed by hands and feet
if 297 is rightful 235 is shotgun if we
have so many more stabbings and
hands and feet why are so many folks
in dc on the left trying to
figure out ways to over regulate guns i
think you should have to do is you have
to break down
the audience so if you're talking about
just a general population of people in
the middle
who are just regular people and they're
not in politics who who want to do those
things they have a different motivation
then you have the people in dc as you
stated who have their own motivations
and i think largely the motivation is
control
and sometimes that that desire for
control is they are serving as almost a
proxy
for other interests that have a desire
for
said control um because what you'll get
is you'll get a lot of politicians who
are getting money from people like
the bloombergs of the world and so forth
and so on who
they've made this issue their thing this
is their live mission so to speak
and so when they're responsible for
getting them elected in these particular
areas and these different races
then they can't go against the person
who helped them get there in the first
place so they're going to
push for these types of laws because
they want these types of laws
but then you also get individuals in
positions of power who don't like the
idea of the common man
having access to the things that they
consider to be high-powered
because they like the idea of sitting on
this oligarchy or this throne above
everybody else because they don't see
themselves as our representatives
they see themselves as our leaders and
so you can't just have a common everyday
man
on the same level of degree of power so
to speak as you are when it comes to
the ability to protect and take life
because the most
most important thing we have the most
valuable thing we have in this world
is our life so from that perspective i'm
somebody who
sees myself as above the common man and
i look down and i was like so let me get
this straight you mean to tell me this
little plebeian down here can own this
ar-15
and then if he decides that he wants to
come i don't know take my life we're on
the same we're on the same page
no i want to relegate this person to
okay maybe maybe handguns for now but
even then i don't really like the
handgun stuff either
so i'd rather them if they're going to
protest and they're going to be angry
with this i don't want them showing up
to
showing up with with uh rifles and
handguns i want to show up with rocks
and sticks
because we have the forces necessary to
deal with that
but you're talking about a whole bunch
of people that if we do something to
them that we don't
that they don't like collectively you
mean to tell me that they can
collectively come together
take up arms and make a stand no no no
no we can't have that
and so i think that's a motivation for
some of those people who are in position
so let's look at the two different sides
i i'm going to give you my view of what
i
see both sides bring in our arguments
and then you give me what else you would
add to it and
agree disagree whatever makes so one
side you got the right side
republicans may say look
you can't take my gun second amendment
was there not because of uh you know me
having a gun to go out there go you know
hunting or getting you know
food it's more for tyranny in case the
government turns against me and i can
protect myself against them so
and the ar-15 is one of the best rifles
out there and no ar is not
called assault rifle ar stands for you
know what ar stands for
so well no it is a assault rifle no it's
not so
why do we need to do background checks
there's no need for a lot of extensive
background ships why do you need
training if somebody needs to go get a
gun today
they should be able to get it i lived in
california in texas and in florida
in texas i can go buy a gun and leave
and i wanted to be that way right
california
had to wait i think it was four weeks i
don't know what the exact timeline was
like 30 days or something like that yeah
so that's that's this side on the other
side is
look at all these mass shootings you
know these people if they didn't have
access to the guns this would have never
happened why do you need all these guns
anyways
why do you need this semi-automatic
weapons what's the purpose of it you
make me feel scared by
all of you owning so many guns i think
it's better if we could become a little
bit more responsible how hard is it to
understand this
why is it so complicated what else would
you add to the arguments of each side
i think honestly you kind of covered it
and but overarching at least on the
other side is fear
it's outright fear it's it's this idea
because most people don't really think
of themselves
as being the the protector or the
defender they see themselves as the
victim
there's a potential victim so when you
only see yourselves as a potential
victim you what you think to do
is well let me disarm the potential
attacker
not let me empower myself to defend
myself against a potential attacker
and so i think for a lot of people on
the opposite side who don't want these
guns out there
they are overarchingly scared of the
potential for people to do something bad
to them
and so for me if i was going to add
anything it's just that overwhelming
fear okay so let's add those those in
there right okay so now let's go back to
guns uh if they take my guns away from
me
let's just say they do they take our
guns away from us what can they do to us
that they can't do today
so let's actually go there i'm not
telling you this yeah
please keep in mind you come to my house
i got i'm a former military honorable
you know my background you know my
position but i'm asking let's go to
worst case scenario
let's say beto aurora runs it he's in
charge and he's the guy and he comes
and he confiscates everything away from
you forget about registering your guns
well let us register because if they
register that's phase one then it's next
one conference i'm just telling you
they're gonna come and take everything
what's the worst thing they can do to us
after they've taken the guns they got
all the guns what's the worst thing that
can they can do to us
i don't know ask china
you're going that far in so you're going
yeah absolutely
why not because at that point what's to
stop them there's nothing to stop them
everything now at this point is really
kind of a negotiation
all the things that they try to make us
do now is really kind of a negotiation
between
them and us at that point there's no
negotiation they can just
do it and then if we don't like what
they do at best they
they suppress whatever half half-assed
attempt of uprising
that goes on and then keep it moving
isn't that what they did in hong kong
so i'm from iran and iran also you can't
have gun it's just the government and
you don't have the guns right they have
it you don't have the same as china same
as a lot of different places on that
side
but what is the most valuable thing you
and i have
what is the most valuable thing you and
i have if you ask the average person
what would they say
what do you think it is if we were to
say the most valuable thing we have in
america
i'm going to say in america our freedom
okay so let's just say freedom is one
which is potentially freedom of what
free enterprise freedom of assembly
freedom of religion freedom of second
amendment freedom a lot of different
freedoms right
so let's say it's freedom let's say it's
uh your voice
let's say it's your life okay some may
say life is at the top some may say
freedom's at the top right okay so
if they take your guns away today
is to do what to put fear into you that
they can't already do to you today
anyways
which is what i mean we got a lot of
things that we're worried about
but nowadays if the government wants to
destroy you
they can silence you because we know
these uh big social media companies
they're pretty much virtual governments
you know that i know that and
facebook's a virtual government
twitter's a virtual government youtube's
a virtual government
if they even want to turn against one of
their own guys cuomo they can do it
they're about to destroy cuomo if they
want to silence trump they can do it
if they want to find you didn't pay five
dollars in taxes and put you in prison
for six months
to defame your hurt you they can pretty
much do that if you think about it
so what is more painful that they can
already do today
that's gonna change if they're able to
take our guns away from us what's the
news they do today that they can do then
so here's the thing though everything
you everything every example that you
name is about an individual
right yes can individuals me as an
individual could they shut me down can
they do all the things that you
mentioned before
yes but but the idea about the second
amendment is about the collective
coming together and stopping and
overreaching government from a
collective standpoint
and and what the gun does and allows
what allows us to do is to serve as a
as a check against a government
potentially doing those things
because a lot of people think well you
know the government has tanks they have
missiles they have drones they have all
these things
so how do you think you're ever going to
defeat the government and it's not
necessarily about that specifically
it's a deterrent because at the end of
the day what's the point of ruling over
people you
you've completely destroyed the there's
there's nothing there for there's
nothing left for you to rule over
so from that perspective they understand
that like look we can only go so far in
doing certain things
whether it be whether it be like i said
pointing out some of the things that are
taking place in places like china
um from that perspective
if they try to do that from a wholesale
collective standpoint
what you're going to get is you're going
to get groups of people coming together
to fight back against that
now if i'm on my own i can't one-man
army to death i can't i'm going to lose
that battle
every single time but as the second
amendment state of being necessary for
the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep bear
arms shall not be infringed
based and people like to say well it's
based around a militia yeah the militia
is consistent of each individual coming
together
to fight against a potential tyrannical
government and so
yes individually they can do a lot of
things to me but when that when what
they're when that tyranny starts to
become
widespread and starts affecting enough
people having the means and the ability
with our firearms to stand up to the
government
changes the whole dynamic instantly yeah
but i don't think they're gonna have
that fight with you
and and the reason why i don't think
they're gonna have that fight with you
is because they don't they don't have to
have that fight to beat you
and and beat a party i mean look in
one one day or one one week how many
millions of
uh users on twitter or millions of
followers disappeared out of nowhere and
they were silenced
they could do that in a heartbeat you
know in one day how many people on
youtube could be
videos being deleted because you have an
opposing argument they can do that
that's not an individual that's a group
right
how many uh uh how many people in the
state of california have to bow down to
what
uh newsom says or state of new york have
to bow down to what cuomo de blasio say
on the handling of covet
you have to do it that's not an
individual that's a majority so
i guess the part where i'm going right
now is i think
republicans uh and the conservatives
are fighting a battle with a weapon
that is 40 years old and they have to
figure out to defend
other weapons today not necessarily the
guns
because uh i don't know if i'm making
sense
no you're making you're making perfect
sense actually yeah now
i kind of agree and i kind of don't um i
think what you're saying is
is excellent and to be honest with you
that's why i'm always pointing out the
fact that
the fight against with the second
amendment is a it's a culture war
it's about the culture and so what that
does is that seeks to
broaden what we're talking about here
because the gun at this point then
becomes symbolic
and as far as being able to protect the
freedoms that we currently do have in
this country
and so i do agree with you there are
other things that they can do
that a gun is not going to necessarily
solve in the immediate aspect of things
they can silence me
i got suspended on facebook for 24 hours
um and i have no idea why and then
what's to stop them from just shutting
me off completely and now i've lost
my voice and i've lost my platform but i
think at the end of the day
there is a point where things go so far
the only thing you have left is to be
able to defend your life
and that and it is as simplistic and as
that
is it's still very fundamental because
at the end of the day
the most important thing that i have as
a person is is the ability to protect my
life
uh the and i don't i don't uh this just
so you know
i'm i'm a guy that has multiple
ars several handguns i served
uh i'm one that came from iran who
believes in freedom of religion i
couldn't go around telling people i'm a
christian
or my parents couldn't i was an atheist
at the time freedom of assembly i want
to be able to talk and give my thoughts
you know free enterprise i want to be
able to make as much money as i want to
make without being judged or controlled
you know all of these things and
religion and guns is one of them but
i i i think there are
bigger things to worry about today and
by the way i'm not telling you you're
not fighting for it i'm not telling you
absolutely
my argument isn't the fact that let's
just set it aside let it happen and all
this other stuff who cares it's not
really a big deal
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about character assassination
i'm talking about silencing at the
highest level i'm talking about all of
those things being an issue today
where the energy is being put into
somewhere where that weapon is outdated
today
it was necessary 50 years ago but not in
2021 i may be wrong
so i'm i'm kind of talking around
something that i haven't want to delve
into specifically
because the reason why i hesitate on
doing that ironically enough is based
around the very things you're talking
about
because they can take what i'm going to
say flip it and say i'm inciting this
because at the end of the day if it
happens to enough people
and enough people are like i've had
enough of it i've had enough of this
tyrannic
of this tyrannical government shutting
me down on my platforms in order to use
my first amendment right shutting me
down
my ability to make a living and all of
these things at the end of the day
yes we can collectively come out in the
streets with guns
and make a stand that's something that's
that can be done
so from that perspective it was
so that did happen so that actually did
happen right so let's go to
when the protesting slash riots happen
but it's peaceful protesting we know it
wasn't peaceful protesting
when the protestant was taking place
this summer during covet
businesses were getting trashed you saw
this 17 year old kids going out there
and just protecting themselves
and defending businesses yeah well you
know the script was flipped and it was
look at these
you know people who are out there you
know look how they're being raised and
they're going around with guns and all
these peaceful protesting
no one hears the rhetoric that you're
giving all they see is what's being told
on tv
and on tv it shows that you are radical
you are radical
nor you're being painted as a radical
individual you are the radical ones
not all the other folks and then you go
and present yourself in dc
and say hey here's what we're capable of
doing and then you know what comes next
oh inciting all this stuff then you're
turned off you're silenced
now what so all i'm all i'm talking
about
is strategically all i'm talking about
you got money here right that's being
put into different uh
uh issues gun rights and gun control
from 1990 election cycle through
december of 2019 gun rights and gun
control
interest groups reported the following
political contributions to federal
candidacy
total contribution gun rights 44 million
total
gun uh contribution gun control 9.3
million
donations by democrats 4 million
donations by republicans 39 million but
donation
so you look at these numbers you're like
okay money's being invested in certain
areas
democrats quite frankly are not really
putting that much money in gun control
republicans are putting 45 million
democrats are putting only 9 million
republicans are putting five times more
into the gun
issue than democrats are right but what
are democrats quietly doing
they're getting their base and their
voice and their audience to get louder
to control what you can and can't say
the more they do that even a great
argument loses
to one who has more eyeballs don't you
agree yeah
but see and they may and they can afford
to spend less on the gun issue because
they already
have the bullhorn that's right and so
and that's
part of the reason why i try to couch
my discussion under the guise of it's
not a guys it is
as a as a cultural war because that's
essentially what it is it's a cultural
war against
the ownership of fires because what
people one thing that i will say about
me and my journey with respect to
firearms
the firearm was a catalyst for a lot of
other things for me that were in the
positive
because it was i remember when i first
got my ability to conceal carry i got my
license to conceal carry my firearm
and it was at that moment that i
realized the only person responsible for
my safety is me
that's the person i can't rely on
anybody else it's gonna be me
and so that mindset in and of itself
starts to trickle into other aspects of
your life
whether it be business whether it be the
way you handle your relationships
that is a that is a freedom
self-sustaining mindset
that honestly does not bode very well
for
a particular group of political class
who
base their entire ideology on the
prominence of government
and the dependency on said government
because when you have people who think
from an independent mindset
it's harder to get them to lean and
depend on a bigger government
we have a problem with that it's because
they generate so much of their money so
much of their influence
from having a bigger government well
they're going to do everything in their
power
from a cultural perspective to tell you
how much you don't need those
things they understand what the firearm
does symbolically to a person
and how it changes their mindset in a
manner that is actually positive
contrary to what a lot of people think
who thinks is pretty much for the
negative
and i'm a walking talking example of
that yeah
i mean look we need a hundred of you we
need a thousand of you
one you know we need people that are
putting this argument out there for
others to sit there and say like even
when bill maher talked to you bill maher
was like
he was a little bit more subtle he
wasn't challenging you he wasn't pushing
you
and then you almost sat there and said
well first of all i respect you the
reason the only reason why he wouldn't
push you harder
it's probably because he didn't research
the topic enough
to be able to have the data to debate
you so it's like look this is not really
my deal
i just kind of i'm looking at and he
just kind of let you do your part i'm
like
wow even if bill maher who is a guy
that's got
strong opinions about religion about god
about a lot of different things
he himself hasn't done a lot of research
on
gun rights and second amendment and the
reasons behind it so
but let's let's take a let's go
different angle here with guns just
curious about that so
i went in the army uh i went through
boot camp i had never shot a
semi-automatic weapon before whether
it's a saw whether it's an ar-15 whether
it's a
m60 whatever it is that we have to shoot
up right and we had a great time doing
that
when i did i'm like wow this is pretty
ridiculous
but i'm glad i had somebody that was
telling me okay put your nose here when
you're going through it looked like and
when you
put you know pulling pull with just the
basic stuff they're telling you right
yeah do you do you think the argument on
the left makes sense to say
why don't we at least get more people
who are buying guns to be more
trained rather than me as a rookie can
go buy a gun today and walk away 30
minutes later
don't we need to have more necessary
training for guns because if i can
i can't get a driver's license with some
kind of permit training that i do at
least a certain amount of hours
why don't we do the same with gun
ownership okay i have no problem with
that and i've been that's actually an
argument that i've made
multiple times instead of and that's
like i have a like part of my
merchandising that i have one of the
messages we have is defund gun control
and and the basis behind that is this if
you look at the number of people that
die each year from a firearm and you
break it down
right 60 65 to 60 percent of those
people are suicides
then you have the remaining which are
actual homicides and that
makes up eighty percent of the remaining
deaths and then you have
five percent um yeah i think it's about
five percent
that are accidents and then you have or
i think fifteen percent of their
accidents and then five percent are like
police shootings and so forth and so on
and so we go through each one of these
things and we start addressing the
overall issue so let's take the
accidents for instance
we can cut the number of firearm
accidents in half
surely based on education
purely based on education like you
mentioned he's like bill maher hadn't
even done
extensive research on his own and he was
having a conversation
on the national platform and a lot of
the accidents that you see
are born by way people who don't really
understand firearms
then you talk about let's say the uh
let's say the remaining homicides which
are
largely about 80 of those is is
gang and drug violence that takes place
in our inner cities in very specific
areas
and then even in very specific areas
within those areas
right down to certain blocks and certain
streets so
clearly that's not a gun issue that's a
social economic issue that's gone awry
so a lot of the things that we that that
we can do
with respect to decreasing the number of
gun deaths in this country can be done
by way of education
so instead of spending the millions of
dollars that we spend
trying to pass law trying to convince
you why you don't need
this killing death machine all that
money that we're spending to do that
why not take that money and put it
towards
educating the masses of people who live
in a country that have close to over 400
million guns in it
like it boggles my mind but no they
rather spend
millions to try to convince you that you
don't need the gun in the first place
while nothing changes none of the laws
that they're passing is going to do
anything to actually
cause these gun deaths to go down so i
agree with you wholeheartedly i think we
should
spend our time our money and our
resources to educate the population
about guns especially considering one of
the few countries exceedingly few
countries
that has the right to fire our ownership
the way that we do
so i think it should be done problem is
we spend too much time talking about
laws that further restrict the right
that actually don't or won't do anything
to actually mitigate the gun deaths that
we do have in this country
well i think i think if it was a if it
was a uh
you know if they raise the money with
permits that we pay for people would pay
for permits 60 bucks 40 bucks 20 bucks
80 bucks i mean
why not why would the government
subsidize it why not
let the let the individuals train it not
even having a government doing it some
you know
well no i'm saying if the government's
going to require so i'm again i'm
actually against government mandated
training in order to get the ability to
own a firearm
and a lot of people don't understand why
and i'll explain it the reason why i
don't want the government to do it is
because we've already
have it's already been demonstrated that
there are there's a huge
aspect of people in the government who
don't want us to have these things
to begin with so what i'm not going to
do is rely on the good faith of
those people in power to come up with a
system
that would allow me to then inevitably
own a gun
i just i don't agree with it because
what they'll do is they'll steadily
start to increase the requirements
with what i get when i get it when i get
my hours for driving who am i paying is
it a government organization or private
uh i'm assuming it's in order to get the
license or the actual training
you know how you go get your permit and
you're paying somebody that's private
right
yeah you're paying privately yes yeah so
i would do the same thing have it
probably like a retired
e8 you know retired e9 a retired e7 he
starts a business
and here's what he does and let him take
it but the thing is the standards that
are put out in order to know that you
have to meet right in order to get that
license
is this place is is presented by way of
the government
and they can imagine that and they can
keep changing that
criteria and uh okay i mean i can the
only thing is for me like for me
do you think it's okay for me to be able
to go get a gun
leave five minutes later no background
check
extensive no necessary lengthy
let me see if this guy's going through a
bad breakup right now bad divorce right
now he found his
daughter with someone wife with someone
girlfriend with someone he wants to
retaliate
let's give this guy one week you don't
think there's a challenge with that
i don't agree with that at all because i
can i can also demonstrate examples
where you have individuals who
were waiting for a firearm and waiting
like for instance in new jersey you have
a woman by the name of carobone
and she was killed by her she was
stabbed to death by her ex-boyfriend she
had a restraining order against her
ex-boyfriend and he was a felon and she
knew he was going to try to kill her one
day so she submitted her application in
order to get because in new jersey you
have to get a license
in order to own a gun and so she
submitted her
her paperwork in order to get the
license but in new jersey
because the people in power in new
jersey the cory bookers of the world
whenever he was mayor of new jersey
they don't actually they sit on it they
take their sweet time
and they do everything in their power to
make it as hard and as lengthy as a
process
as possible in order for you to get a
license just to own a gun we're not even
talking about the ability to carry it
and she was stabbed in a driveway of her
own home so from that perspective
i i disagree with it because this woman
actually called in and said hey
i'm just checking on the status of my
license in order for me to go buy a gun
and they still hadn't done it yet and
they were above and beyond the 30-day
requirement that they were supposed to
have
in order to process the paperwork and
give her approval
and so as a result of that when the time
came and
her ex-boyfriend showed up to stab at
her death she was in a position no
longer to defend herself at that point
and so that's why so for me i'd rather
err on the side of empowering people to
be able to defend themselves as fast as
possible
than to i don't want to say create an
anecdotal situation where you have an
individual who immediately goes out and
says well i want to go kill a bunch of
people i'm going to go out and buy a gun
and do it
because if we're going to be honest one
the examples of those that actually
exist are relatively few
at least provable and two in the events
the most of times when people are
looking to do something that
with that immediacy they're going to buy
the gun illegally anyway
let me ask you this question here's a
question for you what what would make
america safer okay 99
of america who has license to carry or
99 of america who doesn't own a piece of
gun not not
a single gun i'd say the former uh
yeah yeah because i've asked that i've
asked the question before on my show i
said
i caught the big red button question i
said what if you live in a world
where if you push through you had a red
button right here if you push this red
button all the guns disappear
would you or would you not push the
button and people when they ask me would
i push it but not say no
and the reason why i wouldn't push the
button is because that button doesn't
remove
guns are not violence guns are
a tool that is utilized by people who
want to commit violence
and so from that perspective i wouldn't
push that button because
sure i mean i do i've done a little mma
you know i work out i try to take care
of myself
so a couple of guys show up and try to
do harm to me i could probably take care
of myself but what about my mom
what about my grandmother what about
people who are more vulnerable
who are in positions who will
legitimately become targets
because they are seen as weaker i think
a world where we don't have those
firearms i believe the criminals would
become more emboldened
that's why they called the great
equalizer you know the great equalizer
would
allow a grandma or a woman to be safe
going up against the guy
who's twice her size saying hey if you
want to do anything you know i don't
want any problems can you just leave my
house
exactly and uh do you think the argument
of of of of uh getting rid of guns gun
control
do you think it's creating more momentum
today or do you think it's actually
losing momentum as an argument man i
struggle with this so much because
i know there's so much missing like
prior to us coming part of me coming on
here i was working on a video response
um to a guy's name i think his name his
name is igor
volsky or something like that and he's
the executive director of a group called
guns down america
um and they they they basically stopped
short of saying they want to ban all
guns but that's essentially what they
want to do
um and he did a video titled three myths
about guns about gun control
and he went on and talked about how the
republicans got up and lied about this
bill that just passed the house with
respect to
um universal background checks and
i see these things and you know it's
placed under uh
this is politics now and they have a
million followers
um and i know there are tons of people
who are going to see this video who
don't know anything about guns to begin
with
and then they're going to get this
information and they're going to be
misled about the truth of it
so then my little black ass has to come
up here put together a video to counter
that information with objective
information
um but then i i do i do great numbers
but i don't know if i can outdo
the platform like this is now and then
all of the other platforms that have
millions of followers and then you have
a ton of celebrities who are anti-gun
openly anti-gun about things
um like how do i combat that
and so but then you there's another
argument that says well
when you tell people what they can't
have they want it more
right so when you have joe biden get up
there and saying that he wants he wants
to ban
ar-15s and he wants to have uh buy uh
buy-back programs for those ar-15s to
have you turn them in or register them
and so forth and so on i can see how
that can then cause
an effect where people want to go out
and say you know what no i'm gonna go
and buy these things
um but more than that what i think
really did it honestly was kovit
i think covid was the biggest driver
largely because
it forced people to confront their
vulnerability in a way that they never
really had to before
and with respect to their dependency on
the government i am not anti-government
i'm just limited government i just like
my government to be
as big as it technically kind of has to
be in order to get certain things done
but i still want it as small as possible
and so what i think it
happened is when when you were seeing
people get up there i mean yeah people
in that they have
our leaders in dallas saying you know
cops aren't going to be coming out
for certain phone calls right um and
they were seeing the mayhem that was
going on in the streets you had
literally whole sections of seattle
being taken over by people
so when people started to see this and
they realized no i can't just pick up
the phone and call the cops and say hey
come here and deal with this problem
you don't have ubereats protection on
demand and so they're like you know what
i gotta i gotta learn to do this myself
kind of like me when who
uh yes i am the son of an executive chef
but i am not a cooker
but when uber eats stops working for a
couple days and i can't order food
that's what i'm have to do i'm gonna
have to learn how to cook
that's right and so so a lot of people
realize immediately you oh wow like i'm
on my own here even people who are
radically anti-gun
because that reality trumped any
ideology that they had i i hate the fact
that the whole
firearm conversation is even politicized
should not be politicized
shouldn't but it is the fact that it's
so cleanly divided down the middle
between
democrats and republicans or liberals
versus conservatives
is insane to me but here we are and it
is what it is
so to answer your question in short i
think it does a little bit of both
i i think i think some of the rhetoric
causes people to buy guns but then i
think
more so it it misinforms people
and causes them to vote for things that
i think are to their disadvantage
with respect to the issue of guns in
this country because they don't know
there are so many people who literally
think we don't have background checks
for guns
because of the way that they talk about
background checks
because there's a distinction between
background checks and universal
background checks
a lot of people don't know that but when
they do a poll they don't ask
are you in favor of universal background
checks no they say are you in favor of
background checks
it's like well yeah my favorite
background checks but the issue isn't
that simplistic
it's complicated for a reason and the
reason why they call it like to call it
a loophole it's not a loophole
it was purposely designed not to include
this segment
of gun buyers purposefully but they
don't they don't say it like that
and so it's these people who become
misinformed on the issue
and then have a false sense of
information
when they come and talk to someone like
me about the issue
and so then i have to almost kind of
re-educate
then rehab that conversation yeah where
i'm going with this
is the following here's where i'm going
with this yes uh
i don't think they're making momentum
and i don't think it's going to be
something that's going to happen
i think people are buying more guns
right now than ever before the other day
i was with
a a friend who just recently bought
remington he bought the whole remington
brand in november because they were
going through some challenges
and him and a group of investors came
and bought it
and i was looking at a uh you know um
you know what was it a uh
rm 2.1 i don't know what it was i think
it's a 21 it was
you know massive massive you know
uh remington rifle that he had and he
brought it out and showed it to us like
for five stop four five thousand dollars
beautiful thing i took a picture with i
posted on instagram
i don't think you know they're making
momentum in the gun side
but what i do think they are doing is i
think they're sitting there saying
oh these guys they think this is all
about guns this has got nothing to do
with guns
while you're defending your gun argument
that we are still controlling you with
that argument for the last 50 years
we are over here passing other kind of
laws that's allowing us to control you
even more
so you can win the gun argument we'll
let you feel like you're winning
constantly every year
but we keep passing our agenda on the
other side whether it's marxist
socialist whatever you want to talk
about it
we're making progress here you keep your
guns we'll make the progress here
because at the end of the day
come 20 30 40 years from now we really
don't care if you keep your guns
we just care that you don't keep your
voice you can have all your guns you
want we'll keep the voice and we'll pass
all the regulations and laws and
policies that we want to pass i mean
just yesterday you know this came out
this weekend janet yellen
is a wanink g20 uh
to agree to come up with a identical
corporate tax rate
around the world so america cannot have
any competition with businesses wanting
to leave u.s to another country
so they have to pay less taxes and these
countries are like what the hell are you
talking about we want that competition
but they're convincing others how some
of their policies may be the right thing
to be a globalist you know you know
obviously you know this
as much as i do because you probably
better than i do because this is the
world you're constantly
researching and and going through but i
think it's bigger than guns to them
i think they're giving this one victory
to win in five other places
i may be wrong but that's what i think
what do you think
i agree with you but i think to a
certain extent
i think at a certain point they can only
do so much they can't
if if they're if their goal right is
this kind of marxist utopia
or this socialist utopia socialism can
only go so far with an armed community
of people
or non-population of people because if
you really think about it
name one socialist country where the
vast majority of the population is armed
i don't think you'll be able to find one
but i don't think they care if you want
a gun i think
they do too go ahead i don't think guns
are
guns are a big deal anymore nowadays i'm
telling you i
i don't think like like let me let me
put it to you this way
like let's just say i'm the nerd you
bullied me in high school
you have a hundred m16s in your house
you have a hundred thousand rounds you
have all that [ __ ] i'm a hacker i will
ruin your life
if um there's different ways to beat you
today weapons have changed in the last
10 20 30 years
and the one thing go ahead but the one
thing about a firearm is it's analog
and what i mean by that is this is there
a stopping point with the level of
oppression that you get with socialism
is there this is there where is that
where is the stopping point that says
all right we're this we're just gonna
oppress you up to
this point this is the only point we're
gonna impress you
there there is no stopping point it's
it's power consumes unlimitedly
from that perspective so if you yeah you
could ruin my life and you can ruin
millions of other people's lives by way
of
using utilizing technology shutting my
voice down but then it
at the end of the day it all comes back
to one fundamental aspect
you piss off enough people you're going
to get an aggregation of people coming
together to do something about it i'll
put you in jail
you can't put everything you can't put
everybody in jail but but it's not going
to be everybody though it's not going to
be everybody
you have to know i'm not we're on the
same team i'm not at all
on a team that you're not the only thing
i'm on
is uh these guys are over
guns democrats are over guns
democrats have figured out a way to beat
you
in ways that they're not even thinking
about like listen
have all of that you know it there used
to be a time
there used to be time where you know me
being big and strong matter
look how strong i am no one cares today
honestly
body but you you take a guy how many of
these videos have you seen a bodybuilder
who benches six plates
goes and fights a 160 pound jiu jitsu
guy dude
embarrasses the guys like wait a minute
i'm tapping out right so then the
jujitsu guy
as good as he may be he goes up with a
girl who's 16 years old
five 110 pounds with a gun the jiu jitsu
guy gets killed
now the the girl with the 1 gun goes up
against
a person who's a on the basement access
to all the social media and
is able to pull off your pictures off
your phone and post it all over social
media to embarrass you
that person's so the levels of
weaponizing
has advanced so much that if the
republican party wants to have control
in their voice long term they have to
put just as much energy into
having their voices being heard and not
being silenced
as it is keeping background checks out i
think
i think the goal with the silencing of
the voice is so that they inevitably
can't get
to the guns and here's why they
would have to scare enough of the
population in order for them to hand
them in
i always say this is they're not going
to come door-to-door
they're not what they'll do is they'll
say hey we're going to make an example
out of some people and scare you into
turning your firearms in
and and so and then to address another
aspect of what you said the reason why i
disagree with the aspect of the
disagree with the notion that they are
over guns is because
if they were there wouldn't be so much
energy being committed to the
disinformation
to the pushing all the money spent to
get some of these politicians in place
who talk about who's fat
about um oh we're gonna do this about
gun control and we're gonna fight this
with respect to nra and so forth and so
on
it begs the question why then so why so
much energy
geared towards undermining the second
amendment
if that's the case it's been done for a
long time it's distraction
it's it's very easy to distract you hey
i'm gonna fight this battle here but i'm
taking money away from your influence
over here but this is what i'm
interested in but i'm not really
interested in this because i'm hey guys
go go go but here
this is i mean this has been going on
for uh hundreds of years it's it's a
napoleon did it mussolini did it a lot
of great generals and warriors have done
it sun tzu talked about it
anybody and everybody that's in the
military talked about this if that's the
case they've been distracting for a very
very very long time well america is a
baby though you have to realize america
is only 240 some years old
which is very true it's not america's
not it's
sometimes we forget like oh you know
like first i came to the states they're
like
this building here has been here for 128
years i'm like
are these guys really bragging about
this tour in iran they would say
this building here has been fair for 3
200 years oh wow
it's an old building so america is a
baby america
uh uh uh politically look
i think if there's a battle between
republicans and democrats
if there's a battle between republicans
and democrats republicans
are getting schooled right now
absolutely cool
right i agree with you it's a battle
between the two you got
schooled you took your money and
invested it and all this stuff because
you wanted to be quiet and libertarian
they bought media companies twitter was
on sale you could have bought it you
never bought it no problem they bought
time magazine
they bought washington post the other
day was pitching why elon musk should
buy cnn
i said i sent a few thousand people went
online tweeting at elon musk why don't
you buy cnn
because at least elon musk is aware
right in the middle if bezos is buying a
post why don't you go by cnn let's see
what you do to cnn i bet the content
will probably change
i bet half the staff may get fired but
at the same time cnn was created by a
guy
who was an entrepreneur ted turner had a
good motive to do that so
again i think i think they're playing a
better strategic game than republicans
and i think republicans are kind of
being schooled right now i agree with
you wholeheartedly i do i will say this
much though
so with respect to the bullhorn right
respect to the platforms and having the
voices that we have
i think but for the internet
i think our second amendment rights
would literally be cut in half
i think i think the second amendment
that we understand it to be today as of
right now
would be fifty percent gone at best
and and and the reason why i think that
it hasn't been that
is because it's because of the internet
and social media i was gonna say
have you been censored at all or not has
your channel at home and censored or not
really
so yes and no i can't really put a pulse
on how how cohesive they are about
trying to sense me if at all
but there i mean i do run into issues
with respect to
the the gun side of things let's take
for instance my my channel
there are people who have the same size
channel as me and they're millionaires
but i'm not going to get that because
i'm so censored with respect to the
subject matter
um so meaning meaning to so the viewer
who doesn't know
the the the company that typically
advertises on all these other
channels they want on yours because
you're talking about guns so 80
of companies can't advertise on your
channel yeah and so and that's and as a
result and as a result the lack of those
advertisements
there's no benefit for them to push my
push my contents
so they'll so they will shadowband it or
artificially limit
the reach on that particular content and
so
that's that's maybe you need more uh cat
videos maybe you do more cat videos
you know i just i just thought my sexy
chocolatey goodness would have done it
but it hasn't been working i think i
think
you are making a positive impact and
you're very necessary and i think the
world needs you
and quite frankly indirectly i applaud
youtube for letting you do what you do
even to have a platform to have a
quarter of a billion views
because a quarter of a billion views is
a lot of influence if you're doing a
quarter of a billion views you got a lot
of influence
and you're on your way to going over a
billion views you'll be a 10 million
subscriber channel in no time
no i'm just glad i'm just glad they keep
guys like you around
to keep the argument on the other side
and you're kind of tough
to do anything too because you're a
lawyer
you're you know you have like all the
things going on where they're kind of
like what do we do with him
well they ignore they ignore me yes and
i remember i was on joe rogan and i was
telling him about that i was telling him
about a piece on um
what's the guy's name i forgot his name
um on
the comedy central uh either way he
did a 20-minute expose on nra tv when i
had
when i was and i had not over john
oliver there we go
and so and i taught and i told joe i was
like look man i was like i think he
ignored me on purpose he did a 20-minute
expo expose on that
on that platform and didn't mention me
once but i'm driving all of the audience
i'm
i am i literally my numbers were driving
all the audience to the platform so
there's no way you do it and just don't
know about me
so if you don't talk about me you're not
talking about me on purpose and joe
said and i and i and i agree you know
what you might be right i said you know
joe was like you know maybe because he
didn't think any of the content you were
creating was problematic or goofy
because he was making fun of it and so
he's like that's probably why he didn't
mention you
the problem with that is bloomberg did a
piece
where they literally talked about the
platform as well
to the same extent didn't mention me
once and they weren't talking about it
from there oh this is goofy content
they were talking about the ideology on
the platform which is 2a
didn't mention me once and what i think
and i think what they understand
is this you take my content and you put
it in front of anybody who's being
objective
at bare minimum you'll walk away and
saying i can see some of his points
i can see some of his points you can't
characterize me as this
super crazy extremist who doesn't know
what he's talking about and just
surface level language talking about red
meat stuff and just tossing it out to
his audience you can't do that to me
exactly and so they know it's better to
keep the light off of him as much as
possible
than to shine a light on them even if
it's from an attacking standpoint
because because they've tried it they
tried it they tried to dox me
they've tried to go in my background i
guess i'm elaine because i don't really
have
i don't have a criminal history so
there's nothing there's nothing there
that you can get me on unless they're
going to send a honeypot to my room and
then recording me to me or something
but other than that there's not there's
nothing there i've dedicated myself to
this
so i'm i'm just assuming and i'm gonna
and this is stuff that people have told
me
because as confident as i am i don't
want to think i don't think i'm just
that important that they're gonna go out
of the way to create a structure to
figure out a way to take me down
but some people have let it be known
they think they feel like well no
because the more like they shine on you
whether they're attacking you or not
the more people see you and they need
less people to see you as much as
possible
yeah but they can't listen they can't
stop that right now you ain't going away
man you're
you're young you're a great communicator
you're charming you're smart you're
intellectual you can make good arguments
you're
you know you have a background you got a
story you got an interesting story the
story is an anomaly where it's not like
you were raised by
hardcore christian conservative that
your mom always voted for the right and
she loved ronald reagan and
whispered to you about ronald reagan
growing up no you're an anomaly so
my mom still kind of my mom still kind
of is little iffy on what i
do to be honest with you she's kind of
like i mean
when you were like i'm worried about if
i tell my mom i have guns she's going to
think i'm a gangster you know you know
the whole thing that yeah but look at it
look man i got to tell you i'm glad i
had you on i'm glad the audience got a
chance to get to know you
highly recommend everybody go check out
his youtube channel we're gonna put the
link below
go follow his stuff go subscribe to his
channel uh please
continue to make great content continue
to make great content because the rest
of the world
is watching you whether you know it or
not it's not just that camera on you
it's hundreds of millions that are
watching your stuff
thank you so much for coming down and
being a guest on vacation and i
appreciate you
absolutely thank you very much patrick
thank you for having me you got an honor
absolutely
what are your thoughts on gun control or
gun rights do you agree do you disagree
comment below i want to hear from you
also if you enjoyed this interview i've
got two other videos i want you to watch
one is with sammy to belgravano and what
he said about gun control
when he and i sat down and the other one
is my sit down with
mike ritlin former navy seal who he gave
his opinions on biden's stance
regarding second amendment having said
that take care everybody bye-bye